weeks after a Las Vegas man was found
shot and killed in a car his family is
gathering to remember him good evening
I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus
police say 38-year-old Lionel valiant's
body discovered on New Year's Eve after
his car hit a water line near Bonanza
and MLK now the suspect in the case
still on the run tonight Sasha Loftus
joining us now
continue to search for the suspect in
this case Lionel's family shared how
horrible this tragedy has been for them
now they say they want to do anything
they can to help solve this situation
he was a man that made you feel safe
Lionel Valiant is remembered as a man
who loved his family and we just enjoyed
growing together and experiencing new
things now days after his sudden death
his fiancee Siobhan Henderson shared
what she'll miss most we just shared
that special bond you know having the
same birthday there were so many
similarities that we had on what would
have been Lionel's 39th birthday friends
and family gathered for a vigil and
balloon release
police say line now was found shot and
killed in a car near Bonanza and MLK on
New Year's Eve officers are still
searching for the suspect who they
believe drove off in this silver
four-door sedan we just need to figure
this thing out and hopefully you know
they find out what happened his friend
and co-worker Reginald Barbary says
those who loved him are desperate to
find the person responsible while
Siobhan wants violence like this to stop
and so it's important to me for just
this to stop happening to to us to our
children we're breaking apart families
and we're crushing dreams so others
don't have to go through losing so much
and they don't know what they take away
from families and what they do when
things like this happen
now again police believe the suspect in
this case was driving a silver four-door
sedan with tinted windows at the time of
this murder if you have any information
you are asked to call Metro or Crime
Stoppers to remain anonymous reporting
live tonight social Loftus 8 News Now